Let's make some goddamn hamburgers
Last week, I made some of the finest spaghetti ever known to man
AAAAAAAAAA
But today, we're making goddamn ham ber ger
*Hamburger meme effect*
Now I never done hamburgers before, so hopefully this will go okay alright?
Let's just start by getting a pot
I actually know how to make hamburger, okay? I know you're gonna be like
*Unintelligible mutter* Alright.
I knew - I know how to do it, and I'm gonna follow the recipe, because this time, I know how to play the game,
So I know what I'm doing (Very questionable Felix.), Okay?
Just add a little bit of olive oil, and the meat is in here, right? There it is. Look at that beautiful burger meat.
Hamburger.
Put it in.
Alright.
Cook that baby
It's hamburger soup. You've never had hamburger soup?
Let's double up on the beef.
Oh wow.
That looks good. Can we add a third one?
My God it's a hamburger tower. Can we get a fourth one?
Aww that's beaut - AAAAAAA!!11! NO!!1!
Goddamn it!
uh- let's add some cheese on it
let's add some f--[weird voice]: (hamburger) cheddar---
Does that melt ?
Alright, that's how you cook hamburger
NOW
We obviously wanna make some fries as well
so just grab your potaters
Jacksepticeye will like this a bit (watching his family get roasted)
so just chop your taters
Just like that
This is a hard potater
A very hard potater
Doesn't wanna get chopped
Whatever, I don't care
Alright, so let's put these in the fryer
I think I have a fryer, yeah
Cool
Cool, well most of them hit
So now let's
Oh, cool! Alright
Oh that's awesome you can fry stuff!
Ok
Let's check how the burger's doing
Oh that looks........
Maybe we need to add just a hint of olive oil
To cover--oh god, the cheese!
Why's the cheese not melting, dude?
Alright, maybe that'll do it
Alright, let's check on our golden boy
Are they supposed to be black?
Oh, ok, ahh, that looks awesome!
Alright, let's put that in
What else can you fry?
I've always, like, wanted to experiment
with frying things
Like, I've always wanted to fry my...
pumpkin
Dunk it!
Here we go
[airhorn]
And he scores. Alright
Let's just let that simmer, baby
Alright, I think our hamburgers are done
Uh, so let's just take this here
Aaand let's grab a plate
I'll probably grab the biggest plate
Because I don't want---
[shatter]
[weird voice]: h am burger
Alright we gotta make it look good
How do I put it down? There we go
But let's pour our hamburger soup
Oh yeah
Oh yeah, that's what came out of it [laughter]
The cheese looks so good
Oh, sh**, let's not forget about our fries
Okay, they look good. They're good
How's the pumpkin?
Okay, so we need to get the hamburger bread
So what you wanna do is you wanna just
Put it on top of here
There you go
Just cook it directly
Alright, that's cooked
Now, let's put that down on the plate
How do I rotate it?
Rotate...
Okay, perfect
Put it down...
Goddamn it!
Rotate,
put down
Alright, let's just throw it--no?
[shatter]
ARE YOU F---[weird voice]: h am burger
How is that even possible?
How do I put it down?
Are you done? Yeah, it's done
Destruction hamburger bread
Alright, let's maybe grab a smaller plate [shatter]
God-- [weird voice]: b  u  r  g  e  r
frick
ok
Careful now, we will put down,
very gently,
put it down
I NEED IT TO GO UPWARDS!
[shatter]
AHHHH [explosion]
I have an idea. We need the..err...Oh god the pumpkin.
[sad music]
That does not look good
I have more pressing matters
Ok, I got it. We need to u-
That's fine!
Five second rule, five second rule!
FIVE SECOND RULE, FIVE SECOND RULE!
There it is
Ok, put it down
Gently, gently
Are you f-- Goddamn it!
[applause] I did it, I did it, i did it, I did it
[applause] Okay, I don't know how I did it, but I did it
Now let's grab the burger
ok, ok, ok, ok
What the hell is happening?
It's hovering!
What?
[laughter]
Game of the year, everyone
Move down vertically
[shatter]
You know, I can't be bothered getting another plate
I can't even see where you're going!
Oh my god fu--
And where did the bread go?
Goddamn itttt
Drop it
Move down vertically, move down vertically
And then drop it
Drop it
DROP IT!
[gasp]
OH MY GOD THAT'S PERFECT
Ok
We got this, fam
How-how's the pumpkin?
[sad music]
Pumpkin's fine
Now, all we have to do
All we have to do is get that burger on top of---
[gasp]
OH MY GOD I DID IT!
HE'S SO HAPPY, HE'S DANCING!
I know!
We did decide to double up, ok?
Why is it yellow?
Why does it look like that?
What is this?
what?
Is that the ch-- Oh the cheese melted!
It worked!
The cheddar cheese melted
This is gonna be delicious!
Alright, so I literally just pressed 'E'
[ding] [airhorn] [gasp]
OHHH!
That's what I'm talking about!
Now, let's get another hamburger bread
We gotta put--this one we just gotta put down on top
[ding]
[gasp]
OHHH!
Alright, let's get the fries, let's get the fries
Dude, I'm a culinary genius
Gently
I mean that's good enough for me--oh
That's good enough for me
Goddamn it, it's seeping out!
I think I know the trick now
No...
AHHHHH
Five second rule!
Awww :(
No
NOoo
Alright, good enough
Alright
Now, I like cheese,
so I'm going to get some extra cheese on top
How do I get the pumpkin out of there?
Spatula!
Of course!
[laughter]
That looks SO good!
[sad music] NO! NO! COME BACK!
Alright
I know I'm not supposed to do this
cuz of how it went last time
But I really just want to melt my cheese
Just a little bit
Oh god, what's happening?
[explosion] AHHHH!
GODDAMN BLOWTORCH!
I just wanna---oh god no!
[sad music]
It's still a potato
YOU!
YOU DID THIS!
[sad music]
Oh god, no, nono not again!
Goddamn it!
Awww not my cooking book!
Save the cooking book!
The f***ing door is on fire!
Why does this keep happening to me?
This does NOTHING!
[sad music]
Alright, so for dessert,
We're gonna make pumpkin pie
Which is basically,
pumpkin and...
lime juice
That looks good
And then you wanna fry it again
Then you wanna add little bit of extra power on it
It's fine, I've done this before
don't worry about it
And then let's put that pumpkin down
And there you go, there you have it
Goddamn itttttt!!
AHHHH!
And there you have it, everyone
Hamburger with pumpkin juice
How is that still on fire?
Put it out!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!!!?
HOW DO I PUT THIS OUT?!!?!
Alright, well, that was a hamburger pumpkin pie...
Delicious---ohhh not my fruits!
My fruits are on fire!!!
See you guys next week, where we will make Pewdie Pie
[weird voice]: Hamburger
*Download tuber simulator available for free and that's a great price *